so did you know the business of ideas
yes ideas is officially a trillion
dollar industry per year that means
people spend eight trillion dollars per
year simply for advice you ever heard of
a company called Verizon did you know
they gave not 10 million not 20 million
they give 120 million dollars to
McKinsey over two years you know for
what purely for Consulting and advice
and by the way they don't even Flinch
when they're doing it nowadays and
matter of fact this has become so
powerful that Fortune 500 companies as
well as Government like government
employees Prime Ministers presidents are
coming from these big consulting firms
let me give you a list of these names
CEO of Google is a McKinsey alumni so a
CEO of Facebook CEO Morgan Stanley
Vodafone Lego Boeing Best Buy Levi you
know who also the McKenzie alumni
Chelsea Clinton let me continue this is
BCG alumni ready Benjamin Netanyahu was
a BCG consultant Bain founder used to be
a BCG consultant John Legend Grammy
Award winner was a BCG consultant here's
a bain alumni where they're working at
now ready CEO of Nike American Express
YouTube all band alumni's Mitt Romney
used to be at Bain CEO of Dell
co-founder of Intuit so you may be
asking pal I don't understand where
you're going with this do you want me to
go be a consultant on McKenzie or Ben or
BCG now what I'm trying to tell you is
it's no longer about the 120 million
Auto contract of Verizon with McKenzie
today the average person is willing to
pay you for your expertise if you become
a consultant not with McKenzie with
yourself we're going to talk about that
today
foreign
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it let's
talk about what many call is the most
influential company in the world
McKinsey and Company so first of all
they have offices in 130 cities in 65
countries they advise clients like
Coca-Cola Microsoft Disney US Department
of energy FDA Postal Service Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation since 2008 they
have obtained 940 million dollars worth
of federal contracts with the dod being
its top client received 120 million
dollars from Verizon over a two-year
period 13 million dollars from U.S steel
over three year period advising senior
officials on developing technology for
the Air Force and space force to
evaluating the management of the F-35
program they've consulted Russian
weapons manufacturer rostek they've
advised China communication and the
government-owned engineering company
responsible for building man-made
islands in the South China Sea in 2016
the same year they were advised in China
Communications in 2016 in a year which
McKinsey carried 64 contracts for the
U.S government they also carried 137
contracts for Saudi Arabia they advise
opioid makers Purdue Pharma Indo
Pharmaceuticals Johnson Johnson and
malincroft to help them deal with
regulator secure approval for new
products adapt aggressive strategies to
increase cell recommendation that
produce Pharma turbocharged sales of
Oxycontin work as a management
consulting firm for the opioid industry
over a 15-year period they work with
Jewel from 2017 to 2019 know what jewel
does is that Vape company I'm sure
you've heard of Jewel tobacco companies
insurance and hospitals you name it
they've done it all and by the way I can
tell you the same thing with Bain and
BCG I'm trying to give you a history of
how powerful some of these companies are
so when it comes down to Consulting
companies they talk about three
different types one is the mbb you'll
hear about one is m stands for McKenzie
and Company b stands for Bain and
Company and the other b stands for BCG
they're known for being the most
prestigious strategy and management
consulting firms in the world then the
big four firms are Deloitte PWC ey and
KPMG these are other management
consulting and accounting services
referred to as the big four as they're
the largest accounting firms of course
accounting gets Consulting these guys
are more strategy so for strategy it's
more BCG McKinsey and Bane but since
they had accounting which is part of
Consulting these are the guys that are
considered the big four and then you
have the boutique consulting firms you
can talk about all over Wyman PA lek
Rolen Berger and these guys focus on
Specialized expertise or geographically
localized the term tier two and tier 3
and boutique are used for this group and
by the way I would add two other types
of consulting firms to this one being
the types that Target companies doing a
million dollars per year up to a half a
billion dollars per year these guys are
not interested in these companies
they're more interested in the bigger
companies the S P 500 The Fortune 500
type of companies and the last type of
consulting firm is you what do I mean by
you what if you have a successful
marriage of 32 years how did you do it
people want to know about that they're
willing to pay for it what if you run a
YouTube channel with 100 000 Subs how
many people are stuck at five thousand
or ten thousand Subs they want to learn
from you what if you're an expert at
chat gbt the other day at a conference I
was hosting I said raise your hand if
you know how to use Ai and chat gbt out
of 400 people in the room less than 10
people raise their hands the other 390
didn't know how to use it what if you
know how to do it people will ask you
I'm an expert in Ai and chat gbt what if
it's relationship Finance Business
College Planning dating funnels
equipment to buy I can go on and on and
on there's also a place for those type
of Consultants like you so you may be
asking Pat how do I take advantage of
this I'm not I don't know how to start a
consulting firm I totally get it I'll
give you Counsel on that at the end all
I'm saying is the Consulting industry
the business of ideas is changing so
before I give you that let's look at how
the industries change the last 200 years
Industrial Revolution in the mid-1800s
during this revolution scientific
management was introduced using these
techniques firms increased their
operational efficiency by analyzing and
optimizing each step of a task widely
embraced by the U.S Factory managers in
the early 20th century as they Scramble
for efficiency and required measures to
speed up their workers performance then
came the management consultancy in the
early 1900s assisting managers in making
choices improving process is solving
problems new kinds of manufacturing
spark growth and increase requirements
companies traditional capabilities in
1914 Booz Allen Hamilton was founded and
became the first management consultancy
to engage with government and Industry
if you want to know who worked at busala
maybe you know John McAfee from McAfee
Antivirus or Snowden both of them used
to work at Booz Allen then came demand
for financial advice after the Great
Depression of the 1920s following the
great financial crisis of 1929 the
glass-steagall Banking Act in 1933
separated Commercial Banking from
Investment Banking and created the need
for a new strategy in banking this new
law triggered rapid growth in demand for
expert advice in banking Finance
Management strategy and organization
which boosted the Consulting industry
McKinsey and company founded in 1926 was
one of the first consulting firms to
specialize in both accounting and
strategy do you notice that the industry
of advice and ideas was evolving like
people are asking for new advice just
like it is today how they may need your
advice then came strategy Revolution
this is in the 60s and 70s the post both
World War II prosperity in America
created an environment where literal
attention was given to finding a
Competitive Edge in business between 48
and 73 there was very little
International competition in business
Dow Jones bull market through 50s and
60s crashed during the 70s and took 25
years to recover this is when the
strategy Revolution began the recession
and the oil shock of the 70s created the
need for strategic consulting services
so you may say Pat at a downturn yes why
okay take a look at the Dow Jones real
quick here if you look at the chart you
look at 1960 something when it peaked
right look what happened the next 20
years how it drops what happens when a
company Peaks people become cocky they
become arrogant they know it all they no
longer ask for advice they no longer
hire anybody oh we know what we're doing
we don't need your help and it takes 25
years for the Dow to recover because
finally people came to their senses we
need help we need different people's POV
to change our business I remember
clearly I can give you five examples of
counsel I got that revolutionized our
company remember one time sitting down
with a guy in New York about ebitdon
building an insurance company he says
Pat you can have a company doing 10
million dollars a year and this company
could be worth seven times ebitda let's
just say 70 million dollars but that's
another company here is doing 10 million
dollars a year but they're a tech
enabled company they're worth 15 times I
said let me get this straight both
companies are profiting 10 million bucks
yes one will only get seven times the
other one will get 15 times yes why
because this is Tech enabled and the
company that buys it or not just buying
the ebitda they're also buying a
technology immediately we want to spend
three to five million dollars investing
in the technology and we ended up
selling around 15 times ebitda just
because of this one advice what do you
think that one advice was worth to me
Priceless that's the whole idea where
people become cocky and they're no
longer ask for advice all of a sudden
they experience a plateau in their
business or a downfall and this is when
ideas started coming up like different
philosophies by a legendary guy and
Consulting Bruce Henderson from BCG the
growth share metrics which was helping
companies evaluate where and how to
allocate cash among their business units
or the experience curve this models the
evolution of costs with a number of
units produced for the first time could
use your volume to predict cost by
knowing your costs you could price
appropriately the old school pricing
method was to price the new product High
to recoup investment the problem with
that was that it allowed competitors to
capture market share so in other words
what he's trying to say is instead of
trying to make it as profitable as
possible with your product go sell it at
a price point they can get such a big
market share of that product that your
competitors can no longer compete with
you and by the way he did this with a
couple companies wanted to be in Texas
Instruments calculator you've heard of
TI before in 1950 TI was a leading
Electronics manufacturer and his biggest
customer was DOD Department of Defense
so even though they were doing good
getting these types of accounts they
wanted to expand customer base and when
looking for products that incorporated
integrated circuits and could be sold in
consumer markets rather than just DOD
they decided on personal calculator so
they invented the personal calculator in
1967 which was small and portable this
was a big deal because at the time the
previous calculator just in your prior
to that was 55 pounds and it cost 25 500
to buy the average person cannot spend
twenty five hundred dollars in 1966 to
buy a calculator and they decided to
price to calculate at 500 a piece
thinking they were being competitive
compared to the 2500 so then Texas
Instruments hires BCG and they made a
bold suggestion based on their
assessment instead of selling it for 500
a calculator they said you should sell
it for ten dollars a calculator can you
imagine the look on their faces wait a
minute these guys are selling for 2500.
we're doing five hundred dollars why
would we go all the way down to ten
dollars have you lost your mind they
said no here's why we suggest you do
this So eventually TI trusts them you
know what happens with ti in 1971 they
sell three million calculators 73 17
million 74 28 million 75 45 million can
you imagine you're selling 45 million
calculators in 1975 who is the other
calculated company can't even think
about can you think of I know you're
going to say wow I use my smartphone I
get it but back then name another
calculator company you can't they
dominated the marketplace so what ends
up happening Jay Fred Busey who drove
this initiative ended up getting
promoted the company president in 76 NC
on 84 today Texas Instruments has a
market cap of ready 162 billion dollars
and many of you watching this you
probably don't even know who TI is some
of you who do you're probably above 35
years old so what's the point one idea
turn them into a Fortune 500 company
this is why a trillion dollars is spent
every year on ideas and these companies
realize they're one great idea away from
an explosion another case study with BCG
is Black and Decker here's what Black
and Decker did when they hired BCG so
these guys were stuck with a 20 market
share in 1950s for power tools they hire
BCG BCG identifies that Black and Decker
sales increase when they lowered their
prices Black and Decker was hesitant to
do this because they were concerned with
recovering its investment for example
when Black and Decker was selling
ladders for thirty dollars they sold 50
000 ladders that year but when Black and
Decker lowered the price from 30 to
19.95 they sold 600 000 ladders that
year that's 12 times the amount at 39
dollars so what's the difference between
the two that's one and a half million
dollars of sales versus 12 million
dollars in sales lower prices kept
competitors away they use market
research to see how low competitors
could price their products before going
bus and here's what happened to their
revenue 1964 100 million dollars 69 200
million dollars 74 500 million dollars
and if they weren't to get that advice
from BCG they may still be small and
more importantly they may have had three
four five other competitors taking
market share away from them I'll give
you another case study completely
different story this is bauschen loan
who's a lens company they hired Bain but
before they hire Bain let me kind of
give you an idea where they were at so
these guys are selling eyeglasses
cameras military equipment pioneered the
creation of soft contact lenses in the
60s and by the 70s they held 50 percent
of the market for soft lenses and was
responsible for about two-thirds of
Revenue they started facing increased
competition from companies like Johnson
Johnson who were introducing new
products like extended use soft lenses
Bain spotted Bausch and long for being
vulnerable and went to work they
conducted market research like a spying
Network they studied a manufacturing
plant of a competitor by watching a BBC
tape of the queen touring the factory
blew up images of every piece of
equipment and reverse engineered the
factory to do a competitive cost
analysis finding out exactly what the
Bausch and long price needed to be spoke
with all types of eye doctors for
research three months the final report
from Bain and Company to Bao Shalom was
that they were under serious threat from
these new lens manufacturers and they
made the following recommendations there
were three ways to manufacture lenses
and they recommended getting into all of
them Bao Shalom had an advantage of
marketing and distribution power from
its prior success they started to
acquire manufacturers for these two
types of lenses they were not making and
then underpriced the new companies also
recommended getting into high-end lens
Solutions which could be sold at a
premium and by the way this has been one
of the most successful displays of
Consulting they ended up capturing 60 of
the market for new fits 50 competitive
cost advantage and eventually they
achieved market dominance and by the way
the power here goes to Bain because Bane
is watching all these different
companies saying listen you guys are
struggling you're on the right out of
threat you don't know a lot to show you
the case study here's what you're going
through we can help you this is what we
suggest you do if you hire us can you
imagine how this worked out and now
these guys are sitting there saying man
great idea because we got the lower
market share and then we also got the
most expensive lenses in our dominated
Marketplace kudos to Bane next came I.T
Consulting and the big four this is 80s
and 90s models like the experience
current growth metrics were eventually
exposed it became clear that A
specialized approach was needed on a
case-by-case basis simultaneously the
need for I.T guidance and knowledge
expanded at an exponential rate due to
Anti-Trust concerns computer companies
were prohibited from selling their
expertise created the opportunity for
independent vendors to offer I.T
Consulting Services the big four quickly
expanded their services from accounting
and auditing to include Consulting they
occupied the I.T Consulting niche market
and by the mid 90s that surpassed the
majority of the other consulting firms
in size IIT Consulting is the largest
and fastest growing segment of
management consulting with only
operational excellence coming close then
came specializer in the 2000 this was
more about you know strategic management
and formation technology human resource
Consulting digital management consulting
meaning you could specific go to I want
to know how to recruit better people
boom I want to know how to retain better
people boom I want to know how to create
better culture it was whatever the
specific Niche was this came next in the
2000s and by the way you keep hearing
about the evolution the the current
evolution of Consulting is how you can
predict the future matter of fact
McKinsey and Company just bought a
company I think it's 2015 or something
called Quantum black Quantum black is an
AI that helps harness the power of
hybrid intelligence to create unimagined
opportunities in a constantly changing
world so what can you and I take away
from this whole history of what happened
with consulting firms how does that
apply to you and I it's very simple We
All Fall in one of two categories you're
either giving advice or you're getting
advice some people's advice is worth
more some people's advice is worth less
for you and I I have spent millions of
dollars getting advice legal accounting
Finance business strategy cannot tell
you endless amount of money I've spent
here also on decide people ask me for
advice for some of you watching it's
like well you want me to ask people for
money for advice or you want me to pay
money for somebody for advice yes it
happens all the time do you remember how
many years ago you and I didn't feel
comfortable saying I'm never going to
post a picture of my family on Instagram
or Facebook this is crazy you did it I'm
never going to post my location where
I'm at you did it there's a lot of
things that we didn't do before so today
what would happen if you got the right
advice on marriage we just had a friend
that went through a divorce his wife got
2.5 million dollars from him he's only
worth five million dollars some of me
say that's a lot of money he's been
busting his ass for 30 years to get to
that number as a business owner if he
would have spent five thousand dollars
on an Upshur agreement it would have
been two and a half million dollars but
he didn't pay for that advice not paying
for that advice cost them millions this
is normal and personal and business and
content creation so now if you're
watching the same pattern I love it I
want to be able to ask people for advice
but I can't afford this kind of money
these guys are charging millions of
dollars and I feel like I can bring some
advice to others but where do I do this
I don't know how to ask for credit card
calendar scheduling no problem there's
an app for that called minute is do you
have a minute to connect let's minute
think about minute is only fans for
experts and Consultants you can go to
this app look for expertise of people
that have and ask them questions this
guy's ten dollars a question twenty
dollars a question you can do it through
text or video or you can do FaceTime
with them all in the app and if you
become an expert you can decide your
price point you can create your profile
you can share it with your social media
and email list that you may have and
people will come here and pay you for
advice so if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel if you want to start
connecting whether it's asking others
for advice or giving advice download the
app right here take care everybody bye
bye
foreign